Marvel nemesis rise of the imperfects is
one of those weird comic-book themed
games you hear about that was a weird
underdeveloped premise pitch to a
publisher that made it halfway through
development and then they just kind of
gave up on it forever and it never came
out except it came out I rarely ever
hear anyone have anything to say about
this game positive or negative
I suspect that society has chosen to
ignore this game's existence and assume
it was just a shared hallucination
everyone had at the Hollywood video in
2005 it's a product of a short-lived and
apparently not that great partnership
between Marvel and EA that resulted
nothing except this game Marvel then
decided he would much rather work with a
different evil corporate entity for easy
money later on though so it's a beat'em
up fight um up adventure spectacle
fighter character action game with
Marvel characters and of course the
aptly named imperfect back in 2005 I
assumed all of these characters were
from some kind of edgy Todd McFarlane or
Rob Liefeld type comic I had never heard
of before but they were specifically
created for this game I get the feeling
the developers working on it had high
hopes that these characters would be
really well received and immediately get
their own comics line following the game
but the best they got was this 2006
miniseries that no one read
who are the imperfects you might ask
well you got waifu bait basically
electrode that guy you drew in your
notebook in middle school when you went
through that phase um
Jax I guess an Emmy Award oh wait this
one's alright I guess yeah I can see why
none of these characters caught on
though nothing Pleasant or interesting
about them they're all just edgy bizarre
derivative which is kind of a shame
because a lot of people had stock in
this becoming the next big thing and
getting sequels and spin-offs out the
wazoo so half the character roster is
pretty bland Oh
got it back no you know what we call
that we call that a web sling an
ass-kicking this game seemed really
hardcore to me as a kid because Spidey
said ass these days you see and don't
even bat an eye weird how times change
on the flip side of the roster we have
the marketable characters that were
created by more inventive people but a
lot of them seem a little off these
designs are just weird like the thing
has ears no that's wrong and unnatural
Wolverine looks more like his hipstery
Ultimate Universe counterpart just sands
the soul patch electro looks um not like
a lecture I'll say that and what's this
spider-man with silver webs on his
costume where the hell came up with that
idea
they're obviously purple in the comics
now speaking of things that are
imperfect let's get to the gameplay it
immediately reminds me of Mortal Kombat
Shaolin monks which came out the same
year it's a third-person 3d fighting
game that lets you have full range of
movement in the arena and even interact
with objects in the environment the only
difference being Shaolin monks was
awesome and had really satisfying and
responsive controls this just feels
stiff and slippery which is a
contradiction but if you've played it
you know what I mean characters slide
all over the place like they're on
skates
but trying to hit someone is really
clunky and slow often requiring you to
come to a dead stop to do it effectively
or else you'll just start swinging at
the air eight feet to the left of their
heads you have to be very precise about
aiming yourself at the enemy or they're
just gonna keep slapping you around like
Jason Todd wide other people get beaten
up than Janet you know you sicko
you can unlock characters and arenas by
winning matches in the versus mode
alternatively you can just turn on the
other controller and make the other
character kill themselves enough times
for the unlocks that's it that's lame I
could do a better venom voice than that
game the controls are a little awkward
and I really wish I could rebind all the
buttons pressing why to block and
trigger to do the strong attack just
feels wrong
[Music]
eventually though like any game with
strange controls you start to get used
to it the enemy AI is generally pretty
tough but they have a tendency to do
dumb [ __ ] like gets stuck on walls or
throw themselves off buildings like they
just saw Fantastic Four movie which this
game seems partially influenced by
[Music]
hey Johnny storm how's it hangin buddy
sorry about your sister and
brother-in-law disappearing forever in
the multiverse to never be seen again it
must be rough but hey don't worry about
the Baxter building I bought it so I can
turn it into an office building for my
multi-million dollar company that's also
going bankrupt so I actually I don't
know what'll happen to it and if you're
worried about the fantasticar Deadpool
bought it and is using it as a party bus
for his mercenary gig I know you have a
lot of memories in that thing but I
wouldn't ask for it back it's probably
pretty rank in there now you know he's
easy gross guy but hey you can make new
memories with the Avengers team you just
joined that broke up because the leader
was secretly a Nazi clone I bet you're
wondering about your old nemesis dr.
doom
well he's Iron Man now so you know I I
mean karma is kind of a myth at this
point Wow
this conversation got dark I'm probably
not helping I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm just
gonna go All Right see ya tell Franklin
I said hi oh wait your nephews missing
too Thanks so anyway this game is pretty
tough until you master the art of
throwing objects at the enemy from a
distance and then stun locking them with
long ranged attacks once you start
laying it out this game's a cakewalk I
spoke too soon okay even being lame
doesn't make this game any easier it's
just a pain in the ass either way I look
at this as one of those games you don't
play for fun you play it to tell your
friends that you beat it even though
they don't care it's like clocking in at
work well gotta get those storm missions
done today
[Music]
the arenas you fight in are usually
pretty ugly to look at either with lazy
backgrounds a black and barf color
scheme or some combination thereof it's
never a good sign when the gameplay is
tedious the graphics are ugly and
unfinished looking in the game itself is
just generally buggy and on top of it
all the controls are unsatisfying it's
almost like EA forced the developers to
rush this game out to make more money or
something well let's go over the story
mode
some scientists guy makes a bunch of bad
guys for fun and attacks New York that's
it the imperfect sir just failed
experiments of the bad guy the robots
are just robots and really the only
thing that happens is a lot of running
around the same handful of locations
smashing each other pretty uninspired
[Music]
wait what how can the Punisher be
missing in action that implies that his
whereabouts were known in the first
place
it's so dumb what is this new station
have an active Punisher tracker segment
every morning day 1058 police have once
again lost track of Frank Castle it's
almost like he has some sort of hidden
base of operations or series of
warehouses he hides in however we're
confident we'll find him eventually that
rascal in other news it's been 15 years
and we still don't know who spider-man
is more at 11:00 I'd say at least the
first few missions have some production
value to make them stick out like there
was thought put in the level design
early on once you've completed the first
round of missions though it just becomes
a slog same few locations rarely
anything impressive very limited
characters to fight after everyone runs
around smashing each other in various
robots you get through the final boss
and it's just this schmuck not as
difficult to defeat as the flying drones
surprisingly those are a nightmare man
overall pretty forgettable game the
title is more ironic than ever now I get
what they were going for and it had
potential but this is just kind of a
boring mess
hey there subscribers and awesome people
that are watching this video I'm coming
to you with no script right now because
I wanted to sound a little bit more
genuine and not quite as theatrical for
this but I'm sure there's a lot of you
know YouTube is not quite the
money-making platform it used to be it's
not quite as viable an option of a
career field as it once was now with the
way things are currently and I'm sure
you've heard a lot about it already you
don't need me to go into that but as a
result just to help keep the channel
afloat and help pay for expenses since
I'm also going to college right now and
doing both is getting a little expensive
a little very expensive I've set up a
patreon and you can head on down and
donate if you have anything to send we
have a couple of reward tiers
you can view contest or slashers pages
early the first two pages of a
she won are actually up right now so if
you want to go check that out you can
there's going to be a couple of photos
and videos of work-in-progress stuff for
future videos so you can see those as
they come out and you can even get
special ranks in the discord server and
$15 patrons can get to vote in polls on
which videos I do next
so after Ultimate Alliance is out we can
all just kind of figure out which one
and everyone wants to see next um thanks
so much for supporting me throughout
these years and I really I just I love
y'all to death you're all the bestest
and I can't thank you enough and you
know if you have any money to toss my
way you know it's greatly appreciated
every little bit helps but if you don't
that's that's great - and thank you
either way because yeah I mean you watch
the video and that's enough for me
thanks everyone Ultimate Alliance review
coming soon and also some gameplays into
between look forward to those alright
bye